[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
الجوانب
[تصفيق]
وعيد الزمن الجميل مسي يقود سان جيرمان
للتقدمي على نجوم النصر والهلال بقياده
رونالدو
الفرصه الاخيره امجد يلعب الكره عكسيه
داخل المنطقه بالروس
العراق بين مشهدين احتفالات الجماهير
بتحقيق كاس الخليج واحزان واسر ضحايا
التدافع
روسيا تعيد التلويحه بالنووي وتفقوا في ان
صياعك والاخيره تطالب الغربه بالضغط على
عصب النفط
والدينا ايضا
العربيه كواليس انتزاع طالبان للحكم وخططه
الاقتحام عالم السياسه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من الرياض وهذه المباراه
الوديه التي نرى صورها المباشره وتجري
الان وتجمع نجوم فريقيا النصر والهلال من
السعوديه مع باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسيه
موسم الرياضه
وتقام المباراه في استاد الملك فهد الدولي
النتيجه كما نرى حتى الان الى تقدم باريس
سان جيرمان بخمسه اهداف لي ثلاثه
المباراه هي الاولى
للبرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو منذ انتقاله
الى النصر كما انها تجمعه بغريمه على
الصعيد الفرديه ليونيل ميسي نجم باريس سان
جيرمان
المدرب الارجنتيني
والاشراف على فريق نجوم الهلال والنصر
مع صديقه ايضا مامي
في سعد الملك فهد الدولي لقطه رائعه من
مخرج المباراه
وبالتاكيد تفاعل غير عادي من الجماهير
الحاضره
الرابح الاكبر
الجماهير في استاد الملك فهد الدولي
للسمتعت بالاجواء بثمانيه اهداف بهذا الكم
من النجوم بهذه الاسماء العالميه لمسه
بتدائيه اليسكا يحاول على حدود منطقه
الجزاء محاوله مرور كاليس كمال كاريس
لكن اليوم
48 الكره تماسيرا ضاعت النقطه الاخيره من
جانب بيريرا
باتاليز كاو كاريو تسديده ماريرا جاءت
بعيده اللاعب السابق في وسط بروميتشال
بيون اللي لا يقضي وقتا جيدا بصراحه مع
فريق الهلال بدليل انه يجري سبيل في
الدكان في اغلب الاوقات جماهير باجمل
مافيا الليله
يحاول على حدود منطقه الجزاء امام اكثر من
لاعب تمريره الى كانو تدخل يا سعود الكره
كانه الى كاريو سعود عبد الحميد كانه سعود
عبد الحميد حركه جانبي كاريو جهه الامين
الى كاريو كره ارضيه باتجاه الثالث
ارضيه داخل منطقه خطيره لكن
90 دقيقه انتهت
اهلا بك في المملكه يا كريستيانو
قبل ان تركوا الكره رسميا المره الاولى
شوف كيف الحب الكبير من المشجعين
والعسكر كريستيانو رونالدو رونالدو
ديس الناس
في دوري روشن السعودي بعد ايام
الكثير من المتابعين حول العالم
[تصفيق]
خارج الحدود ليس فقط في الوطن العربي ولكن
حتى خارج الحدود في اوروبا وامريكا لوجود
كريستيانو رونالدو سيكون هنالك الكثير من
المتابعين
المتتابعين لان رونالدو
لن يكون رونالدو واحده في دوري روشن
مستقبل ست شهد العديد من الاسماء الكبيره
في ملاعبنا بحول الله تعالى الكره تصل الى
الانجامي عطيه يحاول على حدود المنطقه
اعطيه فيها اصحاب التمريكا
قويه وحلوه لكن عاليه حلوه
يا سامي
مع طالب سالم سعود احمد وحكم البار خميس
المري الطقم التحكيم في مباراه اليوم عبد
الرحمن جاسم
يسعد في اي لحظه لاطلاق الصافي رافي في
هذه المباراه تضاف اربع دقائق
ما بعد دقيقتين وفي انتظار اخر دقيقتين
على نهايه المباراه استمتعنا في مباراه
كبيره للغايه بالذات شوط اول وربع ساعه في
شوط ثاني كانت في منتهى الاثاره
ومنتهر
في هذا الكرنفال الرياضي
الرائعه ساحر ليلى فاتنه في الرياض جميله
في قلب العاصمه على استاد الملك فهد
الدولي اللي اعتاد استضافه الاحداث
الكبيره في هذه الفتره بالذات الكره عطيف
ليه هي لطيف
يه اموال سعوديه في استاد الملك فهد
الدولي تعود الكره بعد ذلك
همم سامي سامي
[تصفيق]
لكن
الاشاره بوجود خطا اللقطه الاخيره في هذه
المباراه
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
السعوديه
وجماهيريه رائعه في مدرجات استاد الملك
فهد الدولي في الرياض ونحن ننتظر بالتاكيد
لقطه الختام في هذا القرنفل
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
الاحلام
[تصفيق]
اجمل كره اجمل لعبه الحريف
[موسيقى]
اليسار يساحره القويه تاخذ طريق نحو
المرمى اصبحت اربعه اهداف لنجوم النصر
والهلال مقابل خمسه اهداف
في هذا الكرنفال الرائع ليله ولا في
الاحلام سيدات وسادتي تسعه اهداف كامله في
هذه المباراه الممتعه للغايه بين الصين
نجوم النصر والهلال انتهى كل شيء في هذا
الكرنبال الرياضي على مستوى المباراه طبعا
لكن لا يزال هنالك دقائق اذا انتهت هذه
المباراه
الكبيره والرائعه التي
فاز فيها نجوم باريس سان جيرمان على نجوم
النصر والهلال ولكن كانت مباراه رائعه
طبعا حماس الجمهور واصوات المشجعين
نسمعها
وينضم الينا من قلب الحدث من الرياض مراسل
العربيه للشان الرياضي نايف الثقيل اهلا
بك نايف يعني اجواء هذه المباراه يعني
الصوره واصوات الجماهير كانت اعلى من كل
شيء اخبرنا
كانت حماسيه
تواريخ الاخيره لم تكن يعني مثل المباريات
الوديه المعتاده التي تكون يعني اجواءها
غير حماسيه اليوم عشنا اجواء حماسيه كبيره
وانا حاولت اني يتواجد في منطقه الخروج
والتقط الجماهير التي خرجت قبل نهايه
المباراه كيف شفت المباراه عطني شعورك
اليوم حاضر يلا صراحه مباراه جدا جميله
يعني فرصه واحد يحضر النجوم كبار ميسي
ورونالدو ونيمار في مكان واحد ولا لسه
نجوم ولا صراحه اللي في الدوري و رونالدو
ميسي
الجمهور
الاعلام اليوم شفناها مختلفه اعلام
البرتغال واعلام البرازيل وايضا اعلام
الارجنتين كيف شايف المباراه وكيف شايف
النجوم اللي موجودين والله الصراحه مباراه
جميله جدا اشكر معالم
على هذا التنظيم العظيم لذلك كان اليوم
سعيد جدا برؤيه اللاعب المفضل يعني اليوم
صراحه حدث تاريخي بالنسبه
باريس سان جيرمان طبعا بس اليوم بالنسبه
كريستيانو
افضل لاعب في العالم يا حبيبي
يوتيوب يوتيوب
جميل الحمد لله
ترفيهيه رياضيه حلوه
اساطير ميسي وكريستيانو شفنا نوعين اسمه
سيد يطبقها في اللاعبين الاجانب اللي
يزودوا دوري دوري
ان شاء الله
ههه خلصت الاذن مالك والنبي ميسي الان
ماشي خلاص
احب اشكركم على المستشارتك يا الشيخ
الفعليه جميله
وجماعنا واحب اشكر الفريق موسم الرياض
مبارك كانت جميله
النتائج يعني النتيجه الكبيره
كانت مختلفه من المجتمع اليوم حتى
للمباراه ايضا جنسيات
يبدو ان هناك مشكله بالصوت شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهد هذه الصور مشاهدينا اذا من انتهاء
اجواء مباراه نجوم النصر والهلال ضد باريس
سان جيرمان يعني مباراه شاركه فيها نجوم
كبار من كلا الفريقين همم ليونيل ميسي
نيمار بابي همم اشرف حكيمي ماركينوس وايضا
من همم ناحيه نجوم النصر والهلال حارس
المرمى محمد العويس الذي قدم مستوى عالميا
بمونديال قطر الاخير همم سلطان الغنام علي
البليهي همم موسى ماريكا
ونجوم وايضا طبعا همم كريستيانو رونالدو
باول مباراه له منذ انضمامه الى الدوري
السعودي
نشاهد كريستيانو رونالدو
بهذه الصور بعد انتهاء هذه المباراه
اذا الملاعب السعوديه مشاهدينا تحتضن اهم
نجوم العالم في هذه المباراه بايطار موسم
الرياض
الرياض بليله رائعه
وكارنافاليه كما وصفها معلق المباراه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قلى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان اقامه دوله فلسطينيه سيكون
شرطا مسبقا لاقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه مع
اسرائيل وقال الامير فيصل بن فرحان في
مقابله مع تلفزيون
ان الاستقرار الحقيقي في المنطقه لن يتحقق
الا من خلال اعطاء الامل للفلسطينيين من
خلال منح الفلسطينيين الكرامه مشيرا الى
ان ذلك ياتي من خلال منحهم دولتهم وهذه هي
الاولويه
[موسيقى]
في العراق
توجد منذ قليل المنتخب العراقي بلقب بطوله
كاس الخليج 25 التي اقيمت في البصره جاء
ذلك بعد الفوز على نظيره المنتخب العماني
بثلاثه اهداف لهدفين ليحقق العراق رابعه
القابه في البطوله والاول منذ خمسه و 30
عاما
لكن وسط الفرحه العراقيه ما تزال تداعيات
حادث التدافع الذي وقع قبيل المباراه
بساعات تلقي بظلالها على المشهد فحتى الان
اعلن عن قتيل واحد على الاقل وقرابه 80
اصابه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله الله
[موسيقى]
الدكتور
مهند يعني من الذي يتحمل المسؤوليه ما حصل
مبروك
هذا الفوز الكبير بيستاهلوا اهل البصره
وكل نجوم العراق ولكن ناسف لحدوث هكذا
حوادث تدافع من المسؤول الاول عنها ومن
المسؤول عن التنظيم هكذا فاعليه
شكرا جزيلا تحياتي لكم الاستاذ المشاهدين
ومبارك لشعبنا العراقي ولاشقاؤنا في
الخليج العربي الذين كانوا شركاء في
النجاح الذي تحقق لكن على الرغم مما تحقق
والفرحه التي تعم الان الشارع العراقي ما
حصل صباح هذا اليوم اعتقد بانه يعود الى
اسباب تنظيميه اكثر منها اسباب امنيه
محافظه البصره تستضيف اعداد كبيره جدا من
الجماهير من داخل العراق ومن خارج العراق
منذ قبل يوم سته يناير يوم انطلاق البطوله
لكن ما حصل بتقديره انه تتحمله الاداره
على مستوى المحافظه محافظه البصره قياده
عمليات البصره وايضا اللجنه المنظمه ربما
يقع عليها التقصير الاقل في هذا الصدد
يعني ال- ال- المعلومات التي اشارت الى
دخول ما يقارب 500,000 متفرج او من
الجماهير القادم من المحافظات العراقيه
بكل تاكيد كان يفترض ان تحصل عمليات تنظيم
ان تحصل هنالك خطوط همم تمن هكذا حالات
لكن اتصور بانه على الرغم من ما حصل همم
يعني باعتبار انه العراق ينظم بطوله للمره
الاولى بعد حوالي اربعه عقود قد يكون نقص
الخبره وقد يكون بعض التماهي او بعض
التقصير الذي يقع على عاتق الجهات
المسؤوله هو السبب في هذا الامر لكن بكل
تاكيد اعتقد بانهما حصل همم يعني كان
شائبه في نجاح هذه البطوله على بساطه
بساطتها وعلى ما قدمه العراقيون وما
تشرفنا به من زياره اشقائنا في دول الخليج
العربي اعتقد بانه يجب ان تكون هنالك
الكثير من الاجراءات والاجراءات التنظيميه
اقصد هنا من اجل استكمال هذا النجاح وعكس
هذا النجاح الرياضي على مستويات رياضيه
مستقبليه وعلى مستويات سياسيه بتقدير انه
همم العراق قبل خليجي 25 ليس كما بعده على
المستوى السياسي دكتور مهند ولكن كيف سمح
اصلا لهذه الاعداد الكبيره من المشجعين
بالوصول الى حتى بوابات الاستاد يعني
لماذا لم يتم انشاء مثلا منطقه تجمع امنه
تنظيميه يعني تمهد للدخول الامن الى
الاستاد
بالضبط هذه النقطه الاساسيه وتتحملها
لقياده عمليات البصره والقوه الماسكه
للارض فضلا عن ذلك يعني اداره محافظه
البصره هي قدمت الكثير وسعت لانجاح هذه
البطوله لكن اتصور بانهما حصل من تقصير
هذا اليوم هو تتحمل يتحمل مسؤوليته هذه
الجهات تحديدا الجهات همم يعني الحكومه
البصره وايضا الجهات الامنيه وبالتالي
اعتقد بانه لو لم يتم تدارك الامر مبكرا
وعبر الكثير من الاجراءات همم التي لا
يمكن وصف اتفاقيه هي كانت اجراءات لاحقه
ربما اجلت المباراه وكانت هنالك تصريحات
واضحه من الاتحاد الخليج العربي في ما
يتعلق بتاجيل المباراه او حتى نقلها وكان
هذا الامر سيكل انت كاس كبيره للعراق وهو
يسعى الى ان يكون خليجي بصره مفتاحا لعوده
همم استضافه البطولات ورفع الحظر الكروي
على العراق بالتالي اعتقد بانه المشاكل
موجوده في العراق على المستوى الاداري
وعلى المستوى السياسي بكل تاكيد تظهر فيها
كذا محافل ويعود هذا الامر ايضا الى
الاخفاق والى الهشاشه التي تعاني منها بعض
مؤسسات الدوله العراقيه كان ينبغي ان يتم
التعامل مع بطوله البصره باقصى درجات
الحذر والتنظيم ومنع اي حالات من الممكن
ان تعكر هكذا اجواء وتذهب ضحايا وللاسف
يعني الكثير من الجرحى ومن المصابين وفي
ذات الوقت تقدم تعازي قال لي ذوي الضحايا
وايضا همم الشفاء العاجل للمصابين لكن
اعتقد بانه تتويج العراق بهذه البطوله
ربما ساهم في التخفيف من حده هذه المساله
لكن اعتقد بها انه ستنظر هذه المساله ويجب
ان تنظر وينبغي ان تنظر على المستوى على
اعلى المستويات في العراق وان تنقل الصوره
بشكل واضح ان الاتحاد الدولي والى الاتحاد
الخليجي حتى الى ال- ال- دوله عمان
الشقيقه التي ربما يعني همم لاقى جماهيرها
بعض الصعوباتولهم الى ملعب المباراه وكان
هذا يحج في نفس العراقين ان تحصل هكذا
مشاكل وهكذا اخفاقات شكرا جزيلا لك من
اربيل الدكتور مهند الجنابي الباحث
السياسي والامني
نبقى في العراق ولكن في ملف اخر فرهما
اعلنا الانتصار قبل خمس سنوات على تنظيم
داعش الا انا ضربات التنظيم ما تزال
تستهدف العراقيين وتوقعوا قتلى وجرحه انا
في هجمات التنظيم مؤخرا وقعت في قريه
البوبالي التي تقع على بعد سبعين كيلومترا
شمال بغداد حيث قتل عسكريون ومدنيون من
ابناء القريه وبحسب عقدين في الشرطه
العراقيه تحدث لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه
فان عناصر داعش يختبئون في المناطق
الريفيه
ويواصلون شلن الهجمات بشكل متفرقه ويشرح
وق- مقام قضاء الخالص حيث تقع البوبالي ان
المنطقه اصبحت منطقه عبور للمتطرفين خاصه
وان الحدود غير ممسوكه بين محافظتي ديالا
وصلاح الدين وبحسب تقرير لمجلس الامن
الدولي نشر في يوليو من عام 2022 يملك
التنظيم ما بين سته الاف الى 10 مقاتل
منتشرين بين سوريا والعراق يتركزوا معظمهم
في المناطق الريفيه التحدي اذا ما يزال
قائما ويبدو ان على اجهزه الامن العراقيه
تدارك الامر سريعا منتظر الرشيد من بغداد
تعملوا على كبح نشاط تنظيم داعش في المثلث
الذي يربط محافظات كركوك وصلاح الدين
وديالا من خلال الاتي رصد تحركات تنظيم
داعش وتوجيه ضربات جويه استباقيه الى
مخابئه في المناطق البعيده الاستعانه
بكاميرات حراريه وطائرات مسيره لمنع عناصر
التنظيم من الاقتراب من القرى والبلدات
النائيه تجفيفه ما تبقى من مصادر تمويل
التنظيم داخله وخارج البلاد واخيرا ضبط
الحدود مع سوريا عبره اقامه جدار وخنادقه
مزوده بكاميره حراريه
بعد الهزيمه انك راء التي الحقتها قواتنا
الامنيه البطله
بالتنظيمات ارهابيه المتمثله باداعش
ارهابي وبعدين كان وجودهم علنيا
وبعد الهزيمه اصبح وجودهم مخفيا
ويتمثل هذا الخفاء بالخلايا النائمه وهذا
وهذا يتطلب اييه جهود استخباري ساند الجهد
الميداني بعد انتهينا منه
[موسيقى]
نوع من
المشاكل على الحدود بيننا بين سوريا
قواتنا الامنيه وكذلك همم ممكن الاستعانه
همم
هذه محافظات او هذه تلك المناطق الحدوديه
يعني يجب توفير كافه الاجهزه اللي ممكن
انه تفيدنا بحمايه الحدود اللي هي ممكن
تكون كانها كاميرات حراريه ممكن تكون
اجهزه انذار رادارات همم
اي اجهزه ممكن توفره ممكن نستفاد من الدول
المتطوره بها همم
للقضاء على فلول داعش الارهابيه
ثانيا وضع قوات اضافيه على الحدود
بين العراق والدول المجاوره خلاص من داعش
الارهابيه
[موسيقى]
عمالقه
28,000 من مايكروسوفت وامازون
[موسيقى]
اي نوع قلم اول شكوى
للحين ما تلاقي اللي يحررك منه
بس هذيك اللحظه اللي بتبدا تشعر فيها انك
اخيرا بتتحرر منا هي نفس اللحظه اللي
بتشعر فيها انك رجعت لطبيعتك زي في اي يوم
طبيعي
[موسيقى]
ايش ما كان نوع المك
التحرر من الالم يبدا بباندول
ما هي ابرز الحضارات الخارجيه اللي كانت
على اتصال مع الجزيره العربيه كنا نقول
دائما الجزيره العربيه هي فسيفساء في
جغرافيتها وفي بيئتها وفي ثقافتها وفي
عاداتها وفي تقاليدها اثارنا نحن في
الجزيره العربيه كم اللي موجود منها خارج
الجزيره العربيه المتاحف الاجنبيه
انا اؤمن انه المتحف والمسرح الذي تقام
عليه قطع الاثريه الاستاذ الدكتور سليمان
الذياب عالم الاثار السعودي واستاذ اللغات
والكتابات العربيه
الثالثه العربيه
[موسيقى]
لكم ان تتخيلوا ان جميع طرقات هذه القريه
بهذا الشكل الدمار هائل جدا هذه كانت
مدينه حرب في شوارع موجه تتفقدها تتفقد
الطرقات وتجد صدفه جثه في احدى الطرقات
هذا ما حدث معنا للتو
سنتقدم معكم بحذر شديد لانه ربما تكون
هنالك ذخيره او قنابل هنالك قنابل يدويه
هنالك ذخيره واليات عسكريه مدمره في كل
مكان اينما نظرت تجد اليات عسكريه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد يبدو ان افغانستان التي
تتهم فيها طالبان حقوق الانسان كافه
وبخاصه حقوق المراه على موعد مع تغيير
سياسي من احد العالمين ببواطن الامور رحمه
الله نبيل الذي كان يشغل سابقا منصب رئيس
الاستخبارات الافغانيه قرر ان يعود الى
الساحه لكن ليس من باب الامن هذه المره
وانما من باب السياسه العوده لن تكون على
الارض بالتاكيد وانما من خارج الحدود لان
الوضع الحالي حرج ومعقد لكن رغم ذلك لابد
من محاوله لتشكيل حزب يشارك في الحياه
السياسيه نبيل اعلن عن تشكيل الحزب تحت
اسم حزب الحريه الوطنيه الافغاني مؤكدا
انه يريد حكومه لا مركزيه اضاف ان مجلس
القياده فيه مؤقته حتى التشاور مع بقيه
الاطراف الراغبه بالانضمام حزب الجديد ومن
ثم الاعلان عن مجلس القياده واعضاء الحزب
الخطوط العريضه لاجنده الحزب عكسها اعلان
التاسيس من نبيل حيث اتهم طالبان
بالاستيلاء على السلطه في عام 2021 لكن هو
ارجع الامر لصفقه خارجيه وسوء اداره
داخليه حولت جميعها افغانستان في النهايه
الى بؤره للارهاب الدوليه
تم تسليم بلادنا الى طالبانا نتيجه صفقه
الخارجيه في الخامس عشر من اغسطس 2020
ونتيجه لسوء اداره قاده الحكومات السابقه
وخاصه اشرف غني الذي فر من البلاد بعد ان
اصبحت افغانستان بؤره للارهاب الدوليه
لحقوق الانسان وحقوق المراه والاباده
الجماعيه الى جانب انتهاكات الكرامه
الانسانيه والفصل العنصريه بين الجنسين
وضد الاقليات
وذكر نبيل بان اطلاق الحزب ياتي من اجل
الوصول الى فتره انتقاليه لحكومه جديده
بهدف اقامه نظام سياسي شرعي وتحكيم
القانون على اساس القيم العالميه
للديمقراطيه والاراده الحره للشعب
الافغاني واشار الى ان الحزب يمكنه النضال
مع باقي الافغان بشكل مشترك لانقاذ البلاد
من خلال تشكيل الجبهه الوطنيه المتحده
التي تضم احزاب سياسيه ومؤسسات المجتمع
المدني والشخصيات المستقله في البلاد نبيل
حذر من ان افغانستان على وشك السقوط في
مستنقع الحروب الداخليه الداميه وحدوث
كارثه انسانيه لا يمكن اصلاحها ووجهها
كلامه لطالبان لم يفوت الاوان بعد التوقف
عن فرد المزيد من العنف والاكراه واحتكار
السلطه وما هي حرياتي لم يفوت الاوان
للقبول باراده الشعب الافغانيه
وانضم الينا رئيس الاستخبارات الافغانيه
السابقه رحمه الله نبيل اهلا بك معنا في
العربيه 360 سيد رحمه الله يعني اود ان
ابدا حديث معك اليوم بمعرفه رايك بما مرت
به افغانستان
وما هي اهم الاخطاء التي وقعت بها حكومه
اشرف غني واوصلت البلاد الى ما هي عليه
الان
شكرا
معكم في هذا البرنامج
اسمحي لي طبله الاجابه على سؤالي كي ان
اقول انه خلال صفقه الدوحه التي تسميها
السلام بالوكاله حيث ان هذا سمح لطالبان
بان تقبل على انها تغيرت وكان هناك توقعات
من الافغانيين والمجتمع الدولي بان ربما
حركه طالبان قد تغيرت حقيقه
عام
1996 في الفتره من 1996 و21 ولكنه ذلك لم
يحدث
في تصريحي
السلام بالوكاله ادى الى ما يشبه الحرب
بالوكاله في افغانستان حيث ان هناك يربوا
على 20 جماعه ارهابيه في افغانستان في
الوقت الراهن وفي الوقت ذاته نحن نعاني
همم من انتهاكاته حقوق الانسان وحرمان
الفتيات من الالتحاق بالمدارس والنساء من
العمل والان همم
النساء
لتوفير الطعام
لابنائهن ثم هناك انتهاكات لي حقوق الى
قنيات والقائمه تطول همم
فطالبا وضعت افغانستان في وضع صعب للغايه
ودفع تفغانستان الى حافه الحرب الاهليه او
الحرب بالوكاله
نعم
جماعه
في افغانستان
ولقد ناقشنا منذ فتره طويله مع الافغان
المتواجدين في خارج افغانستان ومع شباب او
النخبه الافغانيه من الشباب
هؤلاء يا شباب هم نتيجه ما حصل في
افغانستان
السياسيه
قاعده سياسيه تسمح لنا بالتواصل مع
الاحزاب السياسيه الاخرى لدعوتها للوحده
لانه في الوقت الراهن اعتقد ان حركه
الطالبان لن
تخشى العمليات الانتحاريه وانما ما تخشاه
طالبان هو الوحده وبالتالي نحن ندعو الى
الوحده مع كافه اللون
سياسي في افغانستان اذا نحن مع الاحزاب
السياسيه الاخرى ان تشاطر الرعاه
نحن سوف نعمل في الخطوه الثانيه الى دعوه
كافه منظمات المجتمع المدني والاحزاب
وكذلك الافراد
للتشكيل لجبهه موحده همم
حلول
للاوضاع في افغانستان وبعد ذلك
بان هذه الخطوه غير مقبوله سيكون علينا
نناقش ما هي الخطوه التاليه او الخطوه
البديله لاننا نحن الافغان ينتمون الكثير
من القلق بشان الاوضاع في افغانستان
ومستقبل الاجيال القادمه
بعد تسلمها الحكم بافغانستان بانها ستغير
نجاح ما الذي حصل حتى الان لا تنفك عن
حرمان المراه الافغانيه من حقها في
التعليم حقها في العمل من حريات التنقل
وحرمان كل الشعب الافغاني من ابسط حقوقه
ما الذي حصل حتى غيرت موقفها
لان الحركه جاءت من
تفسير خاصه للدين الاسلامي
وعلاوه على ذلك فان همم حركه طالبان عمدت
الى غسل لادمغه
وقالت لهم ان من يلتحقوا بالمدارس
الجامعات ويعملونهم ليسوا بالمسلمين وين
باقي ان يقتل والان الحركه نفسه التفكير
في العقيده هي نفسها ولم تتغير هذه الحركه
وبالتالي هذا يمثلوا خطر ليس بالنسبه الى
افغانستان
سوف تقوم تغذيه الفكر
المتطرف ليس في افغانستان فقط وانما ما في
بلدان اخرى
اذا ولقد رفضت حركه طالبان دعوات من جميع
ارجاء العالم من جامع الازهر من السعوديه
ومن تركيا رفضت كل الدعوات التي تلقتها
لانها تصر على تبني تفسيرها
للاسلام وتطبقه في افغانستان وهذا يمثل
خطر على مستقبل افغانستان والمنطقه وبلدان
الاسلاميه
ولكن بعض الافراد كانوا يقولون طالبان قد
تغيرت ولكن الان نرى ان تغيير لم يحصل
بالعكس حركه طالبان تتمنى
متشددا الحياه
وكذلك
همم
المتعلمين وباسبب ذلك فان المتعلمين
الافغان قد فروا من همم البلاد لانهم لا
يرون اي مستقبلي لهم في البلاد همم غدا
اسالك عن الدعوه التي وجهتها منذ قليل الى
الوحده مع كافه الاطراف التي تشارككم همم
يعني همم الراي تشارككم اللون همم دعوت
المنظمات منظمات المجتمع المدني الاحزاب
هل تتوقع ان يعني ترى ردا ايجابيا ان تلقى
هذه الدعوه سدا جيدا وتعاونا يعني بظل
سياسه زرع الخوف
والترهيب الممارسه ضد الجميع ضد الشعب
الافغاني هل يمكن ان
يتجاوبوا معكم
ايهاب اكزاكتلي بيقوللي
الواقع ان الافغان قد تواصلوا معنا
ولقد لقينا سيلا من التعليقات
لاننا اولا قمنا
بالنشر تشكيل هذا الحزب في
الراي العام الافغاني لم نلجا الى التركيز
على القمه مركزنا القاعده لاننا نتشاطر في
الالم وعلينا ان نعمل معا من اجلي الوصول
الى حلول لالمنا المشترك كافه
العمريه كلها هؤلاء يعانون وبالتالي
تلاقينا استجابه ايجابيه هو الخطوه
التاليه بعد تشكيل
القياده مجلس الق كافي هذا الحزب و نحن لا
نريد ان نملي اي همم تشكيله محدده نريد
مشاركه الشعب في هذه التشكيله ونحن نتواصل
ايضا مع الكثير من الاحزاب السياسيه
والجماعات والمهمه الثالثه التي تسعى الى
تنفيذها بعد تشكيل هذه الجبهه الموحده في
افغانستان هو الدخول في حوار
لماذا اخفقنا على الدوام في افغانستان
لا تعمل
يمكن ان نشرك المناطق الريفيه في همم شان
السياسي وكذلك في اداره شؤونني
وكذلك شؤون البلاد وذلك من خلال انتخابات
تجرى في الاقاليم حكام الاقاليم ينبغي ان
ينتخبوا بالنسبه لرؤساء البلديات لاننا
يجب ان نبهد طريقا مزدوج لهذه المشاركه
لانه في السابق كان طريق
اتجاه واحد
فالمركز كان هو الذي يفرض القواعد على
المناطق الريفيه وخلال مثلا ال- ال-
النظام
الشيوعي فان القرى كانت مشتته
الامر الذي سمح للمجادين باستغلال الوضع
اللي همم
ضد المركز وهذا حدث ايضا مع طالبان نحن
نقول اذا انه ينبغي علينا ان نكون قادرين
على اقتراح شيء بناء على الدروس التي
تعلمناها على الرغم لان انا لست
قادرين همم نعطي حلول محدده في هذه
المرحله ولكن هذا هو الهدف الذي يسعى اليه
من خلال
وطن بعد تشكيل الجبهه الموحده بعد اذن
يمكن لنا ان نضع طالبا او رؤنار المختلفه
على الطاوله نناقشها في ما بيننا بدلا من
الانتظار من الاخرين ان يعتنوا بشؤون
افغانستان
بهذا الامر بانفسنا
ونقتني مع هذه الفرصه من اجل تسويه
مشكلاتنا اولا ونتناقش فيما بيننا
ونبحث عن سبب وراء اخفاق دولتنا طيله سنين
عديده
رئيس الاستخبارات الافغانيه السابقه شكرا
[موسيقى]
تتابعونا معنا ولكن
الحريه ثمينه فكيف لو كانت بعد اربعين
عاما من الاسر تابعونا
[موسيقى]
اي نوع الم اول شكوى
لحين ما تلاقي اللي يحررك منه
بس هذيك اللحظه اللي بتبدا تشعر فيها انك
اخيرا بتتحرر منه هي نفس اللحظه اللي
بتشعر فيها انك رجعت للطبيعتك زي في اي
يوم طبيعي
[موسيقى]
ايش ما كان نوع المك
التحرر من الالم يبدا بباندول
[موسيقى]
اصلا في هذا ايضا للدكتوره يعني زوجات
الدكتور
اللي ولع الدنيا كتاب صغير قد كده اسمه
نقل الخطاب الديني
فكره
لانه لا تناقشه هذه المسائل
الخوف موجود في كل مكان
[موسيقى]
حامد ابو زيد الجمعه التاسعه على شاشه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في تطورات ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا
تحضيرات الرئيسه روسيه السابق ونائب
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسيديف من الحرب
النوويه تتوافق تماما مع العقيده النوويه
الروسيه كما اشار لكرملين الى ان اوكرانيا
ستظهر قريبا رغبتها في تلبيه المطر
الروسيه
الاقتصاد شريان اساسي للاستمرار في اي حرب
تندلع تماما كما قررت روسيا ان تلجا
الاقتصاد الحرب بعد ما ايقنت ان الصراع
سيطول امده وفي هذه الحاله تسخر الدوله في
هذه الظروف الاستثنائيه اقتصادها لضمان
كسب المعركه باتخاذ اجراءات الطوارئ عبر
اعتماد نظام الانتجي يعمل على توفير
الموارد الاقتصاديه من اجل استمراريه
التماسك على المستوى الداخلي المدني وكسب
المواجهه العسكريه
وتنتظر روسيا حزمه عقوبات عاشره من دول
الغرب واوروبا كان اخرها وضع سقف للاورال
الروسيه عندها 60 دولارا للبرميل الواحد
حينها وصف الرئيس فلاديمير بوتن قرارات
التثقيف لانها غبيه واوضاع الحكومه
الماليه صامده لا محاله مره شهر والجميع
يت تواعك موسكو في اقتصادها فهو مفتاح
الامداد عسكريا لقواتها على ارض اوكرانيا
وبين ما تجتمع مائه وثلاثون دوله في الحدث
الاقتصادي السنوي في دافوس قرر بوتن ان
يرسم صوره ورديه لاقتصادي بلادته وقال ان
الدينميكيات الفعليه للاقتصاد قد جاءت
افضل مما يتوقع الكثير من الخبراء واكد ان
الانكماش الذي جرى في الاقتصاد الروسي
افضل من التراجع الذي سجلته اوكرانيا وجاء
بنسبه 33%
انخفض الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لروسيا في
الفتره من يناير الى نوفمبر عام 2022 ولكن
بنسبه 2.1% فقط بينما اتوقع خبراءنا في
البلاد ولا اتحدث عن الاجانب توقعوا
انخفاضا بنسبه 10:15 بل وحتى 20% عموما من
المتوقع ان يكون الانخفاض السنوي واثنين
فاصله 5%
لضغط على روسيا اقتصاديا خاصه على نفطها
لانه المصدر الرئيسي
لثروه وبالتاكيد المدخل اساسيه للحرب تقول
صحيفه نيوز بيك الامريكيه ان كاف وضع
علمها يجب ان يتاكد من ان موسكو لم يعد
لديها ما يكفي من النقود وعلى الغربه ان
يضغط عليهم بالعقوبه اكثر لان ما اشار
اليه بوتن حول الميزانيه فهو براي اولاج
اوستنكو المستشار الاقتصادي للرئيس بولودي
ميرسيلي سكي مخادع في السوق لا يقول ذلك
فحسب تقرير المركز الفنلندي المستقلي
ابحاث الطاقه والهواء النظيف الحد الاقصى
البالغ 60 دولارا للبرميل يقضي على ارباح
موسكو المربحه من النفط ويكلف الكريم من
حوالي
172 مليون دولار يوميا مضيفا ان روسيا
ثالث اكبر منتج للنف في العالم تبيعوا
بعضا من خام الاورال الرئيسي لديها باقل
من 60 دولار بكثير للبرميل على سبيل
المثال الى الهند وقال استنجو انهم
يراوغون الحقيقه لانه مستعدون لبيع نفقهم
حتى باسعار منخفضه والاجراءات المتعلقه
بصادرات النفط الروسيه هي اقوى الادوات
الرائعه ووافقه بلوفر فان عاوزه الميزانيه
الشهريه لروسيا بلغ مستوى قياسيا 56 مليار
دولار في ديسمبر من عام 2002 و20 وهو ما
رفع العجز السنوي في البلاد الى حوالي 48
مليار دولار يعتقد خبراء طاقه ان 2023
سيكون عام الحزن بالنسبه لتاثيره هذه
العقوبات التي فرضها الغرب على النفط
والغاز الروسينا
[موسيقى]
فقط
لسرعه القرارات العالم تردد عام 2014 حين
احتلت روسيا القرد والعالم تردد حين بدات
الحرب الحاليه ولذلك يجب ان يتردد العالم
الان روسيا تصدر الارهاب وتهدد بنشر الحرب
الى العالم واخرانيه تقدم معادله السلام
كما يجب ان نتحرك بشكل اسرع من العدو
الروسي ويجب ان يكون تقديم المساعدات
العسكريه اسرع من هجمات روسيا على
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تتسابق شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى في تقليس
عدد موظفها حيث اعلنت شركه مايكروسوفت عن
تسريحه 10,000 موظف بنسبه انخفاض 5% من
موظفي الشركه اما شركه امازون فكانت
الاعلى من حيث عدد الموظفين المسرحين وذلك
باكثر من 18,000 موظفه وارجع تقرير لشبكه
ام بي سي تسريحه شركات التقنيه لموظفيها
الى مخاوف من ركود اقتصاديه المحتمل هذا
العام
تصريح اليوم مشاهدينا سنعمل على عدم حدوث
عمليات اعاده قصريه للمهاجرين التصريح هو
لهنز لتينز الرئيس التنفيذ الجديده وكاله
حمايه الحدود الاوروبيه بالمناسبه قبل
ايام ما اعلنت الوكاله ان محاولات دخول
المهاجرين في اوروبا العام الماضي هي
الاعلى في سته اعوام تصريح لتنس بالتاكيد
في حدود صلاحياته لكن كيف سينفذ وعده ان
كانت الدول التي تلف المهاجرين كما هي
والدول التي تستقبلهم كما هي الا الاولى
توقفت ولا الثانيه قبله
صوره اليوم من برلين امام البرلمان
الالماني صفوف من الاسره ترمز للمرضى
الذين نزلوا يعانون من اعراض الكورونا
طويله الامل على كل سرير صوره وقصه لكن
الشكوى واحده حتى وان اختلفت الاعراض
والمطلب واحد كشفوا ابحاثكم لا تتركونا
بده اليوم
خطواته ثقيله وكلامه قليل ونظرته شارده
ربما يكون قد نسي كيف يكون المشي اصلا
وحتى الكلام وماذا قد تفعل 40 عاما خلف
القضبان اقل من ذلك 40 عاما بتهمه قتل
جندي اسرائيلي زرته خلالها امه الثمانينيه
في سته وثلاثين معتقلا ولم تجد افضل من
عباءتي والده لتهديه اياها لحظه وصوله
المنزل خرج اذا ماهر يونس من السجون
الاسرائيليه لكنه ترك خلفه نحو خمسه الاف
ماهر